[Música]
continúan las erupciones del volcán
cumbre vieja en la isla española de la
palma la emergencia se va a prolongar 55
días y la lava seguirá siendo expulsada
hasta noviembre alrededor de 6000
personas han sido evacuadas y cientos de
hogares destruidos
continúa la asamblea general de la onu
en nueva york en su primer discurso el
presidente de eeuu joe biden aseguró que
no busca una nueva guerra fría en medio
de las tensiones con china y francia por
el desarrollo de submarinos de
propulsión nuclear
y más de 600 haitianos al llegaron a
puerto príncipe- deportados desde eeuu
en los últimos tres días mientras que
miles continúan en la frontera que une
la unión americana con mexico y cientos
más decidieron regresar al territorio
mexicano por temor a ser enviados de
regreso a la isla
muy buen día para todos bienvenidos a
las noticias en france 24 cerro blanco
como siempre un gusto acompañarlos y
comenzamos en españa más de 6.000
personas han sido evacuadas tras la
erupción de un volcán de un volcán en la
palma en las islas canarias cientos de
hogares han sido destruidos mientras la
lava sigue avanzando veamos más en el
siguiente informe
las evacuaciones se prolongaron mientras
la lava del volcán cumbre vieja
continuaba su camino de devastación
miles de residentes en la palma en las
islas canarias españolas se han visto
obligados a huir desde la erupción del
domingo
nos dijeron que saliéramos de nuestra
casa porque había una posible erupción
así que para asegurarnos nos pidieron
que nos fuéramos al menos por un tiempo
con una velocidad media de 700 metros
por hora y con cerca de 1000 grados de
temperatura crece la preocupación por el
daño que la lava podría dejar a su paso
cientos de casas han sido destruidas
para muchos residentes no está claro
cuándo podrán regresar
creo que no será posible construir una
casa allí en los próximos diez años no
hay nada no hay agua no hay electricidad
y el magma tardará años en enfriarse
al visitar el lugar de la erupción el
lunes el jefe del gobierno español dijo
que las autoridades están monitoreando
de cerca los incendios que pueden
originarse a partir de la lava ardiente
pero sánchez volverá a la zona el jueves
junto con los reyes de felipe sexto y
letizia de que ahora mismo lo más
importante es garantizar la seguridad la
seguridad garantizar el perímetro de la
seguridad y por tanto estamos todavía en
la fase de la erupción de la actividad
del volcán por favor extrememos la
precaución no nos aproximemos hasta su
erupción el volcán había estado inactivo
durante 50 años pero la última actividad
podría durar algún tiempo ya que otra
reserva de magma se ha ubicado a una
profundidad de casi 30 kilómetros bajo
tierra y continuamos con la asamblea
general de la onu que hoy entra en su
segundo día ayer el presidente joe biden
pronunció su primer discurso aprovechó
para hacer una vuelta al mundo a través
de los conflictos con la diplomacia como
promesa
en su primer discurso ante la asamblea
general de la onu tras la crisis por el
retiro de afganistán y de los submarinos
de propulsión nuclear joe biden prometió
diplomacia implacable y moderación
militar discurso que también iba
dirigido a rebajar las tensiones con
china
defenderemos a nuestros aliados y amigos
y nos opondremos a los intentos de los
países más fuertes de dominar a los más
débiles pero no buscamos repito no
buscamos una nueva guerra fría en un
mundo dividido en bloques rígidos
aunque vaya de no mencionar china ni una
sola vez en su discurso de 34 minutos
sus palabras parecían ser una respuesta
al secretario general de la onu antonio
guterres que calificó las relaciones
entre eeuu y china de completamente
disfuncionales y advirtió que podrían
dirigirse a una nueva guerra fría el
presidente chino también eligió un
lenguaje tranquilo
tenemos que buscar el diálogo y la
inclusión por encima de la confrontación
y la exclusión
by then trató otros temas importantes de
actualidad internacional prometió doblar
la financiación la lucha contra el
cambio climático dijo que están
dispuestos a volver al pleno
cumplimiento del acuerdo nuclear con
irán si desde teherán hacen lo mismo y
también habló de medio oriente y la
necesidad de un estado palestino para
solucionar el conflicto con israel
además de otros conflictos vigentes como
el de corea y etiopía
no podemos permitirnos perder más tiempo
pongamos los manos a la obra' consigamos
un mejor futuro ahora podemos hacer esto
está dentro de nuestro poder y capacidad
y una nueva era de multilateralismo en
la que eeuu busca mantener su liderazgo
a pesar de la cada vez mayor influencia
de china en el tablero geoestratégico el
presidente baiden eligió este tono
moderada en medio de la crisis con
francia por el acuerdo august que
estados unidos suscribió con australia y
reino unido- para frenar la influencia
china en el indo pacífico y que canceló
un contrato con paris de desarrollo de
submarinos en medio de las tensiones
váyanse el día de ayer con el primer
ministro británico boris johnson para
celebrar este pacto mientras que el
presidente de manuel macrón habló por
teléfono con el primer ministro indio y
prometieron colaborar conjuntamente en
la zona del indo pacífico
y también durante el primer día de la
asamblea de la onu en nueva york varios
mandatarios de américa latina' dieron
sus discursos andrés granadillo nos
cuenta lo que dijeron los mandatarios
anemia distribución de vacunas
inmigración los reclamos de los
presidentes latinoamericanos el
presidente de perú pedro castillo se
estrenó en la asamblea general de las
naciones unidas y tras criticar la
gestión mundial de las vacunas propuso
un acuerdo internacional quiero plantear
en nombre del perú la firma de un
acuerdo mundial entre los jefes de
estado y los propietarios de las
patentes para garantizar el acceso
universal a las vacunas para todos los
habitantes del planeta sin
discriminación ni privilegios por su
parte el presidente brasileño jair
bolsonaro quien hasta el momento no se
ha vacunado defendió su manejo de la
crisis del cobro y 19 que le ha causado
una fuerte aprobación internacional tras
la muerte por el virus de 590 mil
personas en su país
apoyamos la vacunación sin embargo
nuestro gobierno se ha opuesto al
pasaporte sanitario oa cualquier
obligación relacionada con la vacuna
relacionada a battión el presidente de
colombia iván duque que intervino por
última vez ante la asamblea general de
la onu se refirió a la vacunación y a
los desafíos del mundo para luchar
contra la pandemia convoco a la
comunidad internacional a fortalecer el
multilateralismo en materia de salud y
avanzar en la equidad para la
distribución de las vacunas el tema de
la migración venezolana también fue el
foco de los discursos duke dijo que
colombia ha acogido a millones de
venezolanos y que espera que los países
comprometidos ayuden financieramente el
presidente de ecuador guillermo lasso
quien asistió por primera vez a la onu
tras su posesión este año entregó el
balance de la recepción de migrantes a
su país donde dice han recibido 433 mil
ciudadanos venezolanos
y cambiamos ahora completamente de
información y medio de las denuncias de
malostratos los agentes fronterizos de
eeuu y las deportaciones de migrantes
que han aumentado menos últimos días
cientos de haitianos hicieron regresar a
territorio mexicano para así evitar ser
expulsados a la lista el canciller de
méxico marcelo ebrard dijo que los
migrantes haitianos han sido engañados
en las rutas álvaro cordero nos cuenta
el camino que siguen estos ciudadanos
para llegar a la unión americana
estas imágenes de miles de emigrantes
haitianos agolpados en la frontera con
eeuu llevan días dando la vuelta al
mundo es una parada más de un periplo de
meses en los que han recorrido todo el
continente americano en busca de un
futuro mejor la mayoría de ellos vivían
en chile y brasil desde que se les
acogiera tras el devastador terremoto de
2010 pero la crisis de coronavirus
motivó su marcha hacia el norte para
ello recorrieron toda sudamérica
atravesando el peligroso tapón del
darién en colombia y toda centroamérica
y méxico hasta llegar a la frontera con
eeuu en colombia
miles de ellos se agolparon en la
localidad caribeña de necoclí en julio
aquí permanecieron hasta atravesar la
frontera con panamá un viaje muy
arriesgado debido a la presencia de
grupos armados y a la frondosidad de la
selva factores que costaron la vida de
muchos de ellos los que llegaron a
méxico no se encontraron algo mejor
xenofobia y hambre este país denunció
que su situación se debe a un engaño ya
que nunca podrán ingresar a eeuu
imagínense salir de haití y chile
tener condición de refugio buscar
trabajo ahí hay niños que ya son nacidos
en chile con brasil
que ahora sus dirigentes les digan
vámonos a eeuu rápido porque nos van a
dar la residencia o la nacionalidad
norteamericana posiblemente pues es un
engaño monumental eso no es cierto pero
al final de su viaje no está cerca ante
el miedo a las deportaciones muchos han
decidido continuar el camino a la
inversa por méxico
el fiscal especial para el caso de los
43 estudiantes desaparecidos en
ayotzinapa aseguró que fueron utilizadas
prácticas ilícitas para sustentar la
versión del gobierno enrique peña nieto-
sobre lo sucedido según la cual los
estudiantes fueron detenidos por los
policías corruptos y entregados al
cártel de guerreros unidos que los
asesinó e incineró en el basurero de
cocula y le tiró los restos en el río
san juan la comisión nacional de
derechos humanos de méxico reiteró su
rechazo a la versión de este gobierno
de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo continuar con nosotros
[Música]